- [Announcer 1] This UCSD
TV program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest programs.
(piano music)
- [Announcer 2] We are
the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained.
Long the master of fire, tools, language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
She shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts from diverse
disciplines to exchange insights
on who we are and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(piano music)
- I think I'll start off with
an evolutionarily, very strange photo.
This is Heidi Klume, the super model,
with her four children,
and this is an almost
unique sort of photo in
the mammalian kingdom,
and why is it unique?
You won't see a chimpanzee mother
with four children under
her care at any one time.
A chimpanzee mother raises her offspring
to independence before
she has the next child.
Same with gorillas, with orangutans
and pretty well most
of all other primates.
A mother can only have another child
once the previous child is independent.
But here is Heidi, and
she's got four children,
all of different ages, and all of them
dependent for their well-being
on parental care, maternal care.
Now raising four children
at a time is hard work,
and there's and interesting
evolutionary question,
how human mothers are able to do this.
But it creates sort of
interactions among siblings
that you don't find else where.
I should point out that
there are, of course,
other mammals that
produce multiple offspring
at the same time, they produce a litter,
but in those cases, all of those
offspring are the same age.
Now the existence of multiple children
all dependent for, at the same time,
for maternal care, means that they
tend to compete amongst each other
for maternal care and attention.
And when I look a photos like this,
I always like to look,
where are the hands?
And so if you look at this picture,
here is Heidi's right hand is
holding her youngest child.
Her other hand is holding the
hand of her eldest daughter
here, and she is sufficiently rich
that she can afford another pair of hands
to look after her two other children,
so here's one of the
hands, holding this child,
and then the second hand of the helper
is sort of hidden behind her body.
So raising children is hard work.
Raising a child is not cost-free,
and sometimes people challenge
me about that, you know.
But think about it.
If raising children weren't costly,
and natural selection acts to maximize
lifetime reproductive success,
if there were no cost of child raising,
mother's would have evolved to produce
an infinite number of offspring,
which they clearly don't do.
Offspring compete for
maternal care and attention.
That's if your using your right hand
to hold one child, you
don't have the right
hand available to grab another child
when it's getting into danger.
Now there's another interesting
thing about that photo, and this is
that, as is well known, Heidi's oldest
daughter has a different father
from her other three children,
and this genetically creates
an interesting asymmetry.
So all of these four children are related
to each other maternally.
If you picked a gene in Heidi,
it's got a one chance in two of being
present in each of her offspring.
These are all maternal half sibs,
so they're all related maternally,
but the paternal genes of this child
are necessarily absent from the three
siblings there, so this child is unrelated
for her paternal genome to
Heidi's other three children,
and this leads,
evolutionarily, to a conflict
within the genomes of children
over the extraction of care from mothers,
which ultimately translates as
cost of their care having impacts
on their siblings who might
be maternal half sibs.
So maternal and paternal genes of a child
disagree over the value of half siblings,
who share one parent but not both parents.
And so here's the sort of graph
that you've seen before in earlier talks.
I put fetus here, but I'm just
referring to a child here.
We're looking at effects
on fitness of the child
and effects on fitness of its siblings,
and just dividing this space,
there are some sorts of outcomes.
Some things that can
happen that are of benefit
to the child and to its siblings.
There are some things that are of cost
to a child and to its siblings,
and then there is side of trade offs
where some action is benefiting
one child at the cost to other children.
That's the holding of
one child in your hand,
meaning that that hand is not available
to look after other children.
So these are the zones of a
trade off in parental care.
And so just looking at what natural
selection maximizes in this situation,
so first of all, I'm going to look at
natural selection acting
on genes of maternal
origin in a child with respect to costs
on maternal half siblings, the
offspring of other fathers.
And so natural selection is predicted
to maximize this sum here.
This is the benefit to the child,
and this is the cost of
the fitness of its siblings
The child values itself
evolutionarily at twice
the value of siblings,
because a gene in the child
is definitely present in that child,
but it's only got a 50%
chance, this is a maternal
gene of being present in siblings.
So natural selection will favor behavior
when this sum is positive, which is in
this region of the phase space,
what is called matrilineal
inclusive fitness
is increased, but for
paternally derived genes
in a maternal half sib, what's relevant
is the effect on the
fitness of the child itself
because it is unrelated to its siblings,
so as long as the benefit to the child
is positive, natural selection will favor
increasing demands on the mother.
So combining those two situations,
we have regions where there is an absence
of evolutionary conflict between genes
of maternal and paternal origin.
This is where they both benefit.
This is where they both suffer a cost,
and natural selection would act
against genes with these sort of effects.
But then we have a zone of trade off
of conflict within the genome,
where genes of maternal origin
would benefit by the mother allocating
more resources to siblings.
Those genes of paternal
origin would benefit
from the child receiving
more maternal care itself.
This is where the cost benefit ratio
is sitting in between 1/2 and zero.
This is the zone of intragenomic conflict.
And for the second half of the talk,
I'm just going to look at some human
genetic disorders where genes,
so called imprinted genes, have an effect,
and these provide clues about the action
of this evolutionary conflict
during human evolution.
Now an imprinted gene is a gene
that is expressed differently,
whether you get it from
your mother or your father.
It has a imprint, a record,
of its past history,
what sex of body it was in
in the previous generation,
and that effects what it does
in the current generation.
So paternally derived genes in offspring
are predicted to favor greater demands
on mothers than will
maternally-derived genes in offspring.
And so here, we will look at an example
of a chromosome region
on human chromosome 11,
where there are some imprinted genes.
Let's focus here, this
is a gene called IGF2
for insulin-like growth factor two.
Here, we're looking at the chromosome
a child gets from its mother,
and on this chromosome,
I've got a red dot there.
The IGF2 gene is not being expressed,
whereas on the copy that the
child gets from its father,
the IGF2 gene is being expressed.
IGF2 is a fetal growth enhancer.
This is a gene that is promoting growth
at the placenta and is
increasing birth weight,
and it's not being expressed when it comes
from the mother but being expressed
when it comes from the father.
Now, this is called imprinting
because this isn't anything to do
with the DNA sequence itself.
In my body, the copy of
IGF2 I got from my mother
is silent, but if I pass that silent copy
on to my children, it's going to be active
in my children because they
got it from their father.
In this chromosome
region, there is a second
gene with the opposite
pattern of imprinting, CDKN1C.
This is a cyclin-dependent
kinase inhibitor.
This is an inhibitor of
progression through the cell cycle,
so this is stopping cells
dividing and growing larger,
so this is an inhibitor of growth,
and it chose the opposite
pattern of imprinting.
It's expressed off the
maternal chromosome,
so the gene coming from the mother
is acting to reduce
growth, whereas the gene
copy coming from the father is silent.
So in essence, we have a situation
where simultaneously
during fetal development,
we have a paternal foot on the accelerator
of growth here, of IGF2 being expressed
from the paternal
chromosome promoting growth.
The maternal foot is off the accelerator,
but the maternal foot is on the brake
reducing growth, and the
paternal foot in the child,
in the same cells, is not
applied to that brake,
and normal fetal development is determined
by the balance of paternal
acceleration and maternal braking.
And so, this internal
conflict can be revealed
in rare genetic disorders where
parts of this process go wrong.
So I'll start off with a look
at Beckwith-Wiedemann syndrome.
This is a fetal overgrowth syndrome,
so these children are born rather large.
I have a friend who had
Beckwith-Wiedemann syndrome
as a child, and she's given
me her baby photo to look at.
So here she is.
She was about 13 pounds at birth.
Typical of Beckwith-Wiedemann syndrome,
she has macroglossia,
which is just what medical
people use to say, it's Latin
for having a large tongue.
I suspect evolutionarily this is,
the tongue muscle is the
pump during breastfeeding,
and so paternal genes
are particularly involved
in promoting the development
of the tongue muscles.
Now what are the causes of
this fetal overgrowth syndrome?
In a number of cases, individuals
turn out to have two paternal copies
of this chromosomal region.
This is called paternal
uniparental disomy,
so in this case, they have two copies
of IGF2, they have two paternal
feet on the accelerator,
and no maternal feet on the brake,
so they have fetal overgrowth.
It's also associated with a high risk
of a number of childhood cancers.
Some other people with the same diagnosis
of Beckwith-Wiedemann
syndrome of fetal overgrowth,
have a mutation, an inactivating mutation
in the maternal copy of CDKN1C,
so this is the brake on fetal growth,
so the maternal copy, which
is normally expressed,
is inactivated by a mutation.
The paternal copy is
inactivated as normally occurs,
and so in this case,
they've got a paternal
foot on the accelerator of growth,
and no maternal foot on the brake,
and this is associated
with fetal overgrowth
and a similar clinical diagnosis,
though apparently not with increased
risk of childhood cancers.
Such a condition is interesting if,
if a male who had this mutation
and had Beckwith-Wiedemann syndrome
passed the mutant gene on to his children,
they would have normal development
because they would get a normal gene
from their mother and the mutant gene
that is coming from the affected male
would have been inactivated anyways,
so this is a case where a mutation
is having an effect when inherited
from a parent of one sex but not from
a parent of the other.
Silver-Russell syndrome is a intrauterine
growth retardation syndrome, and so here,
I have a picture of two
girls at the same age.
This little girl here has
Silver-Russell syndrome.
It's associated with
very low birth weight.
Not associated with catch up growth,
so if not treated, these individuals
grow up to be very small adults.
It's also associated with severe
feeding difficulties as an infant.
Some individuals with
Silver-Russell syndrome
have two maternal copies
of this chromosome region.
So now they have no paternal foot
on the accelerator of growth
and two maternal feet on the brake
associated with intrauterine
growth retardation
and small birth weight.
Other individuals have a loss of DNA
methylation at what is
called the imprinting
control region one here, this leads
to the inactivation of the paternal copy
of IGF2, so now they have
no foot on the accelerator
of growth and that's associated
with intrauterine growth retardation.
For the final part of the talk,
I want to talk about a
different pair of syndromes
that are associated with a different
cluster of imprinted genes.
These reside on human chromosome 15,
and here the imprinting is specific
to the brain and doesn't
occur in most other tissues.
I won't go into the details
of naming these genes,
just to point out that there
are some genes, like this one here,
that are not expressed on
the maternal chromosome
but are expressed on
the paternal chromosome,
and other genes with the
opposite pattern of expression
expressed on the maternal chromosome
but not on the paternal chromosome.
Some interesting things in this region.
Here is where the single
nucleotide polymorphism
that in European populations
makes the difference
between blue and brown eyes resides.
And sitting here, a gene
that I won't talk about.
This gene, Makorin 3, so this is a gene
that is only expressed when
you get from your father
but not expressed from the mother.
When children have a
mutation in this paternally
derived gene copy, recent work from Brazil
said they have precocious puberty,
that they go through puberty usually
before age of 10 years,
so this is suggesting
that the paternally expressed gene
on this chromosome is
inhibiting pubertal progression,
which raises some interesting
evolutionary questions.
Okay, so here is a young child
with Prader-Willi syndrome.
I'm going to focus on the childhood
symptoms of Prader-Willi syndrome.
These children, some of you might know
in studying in their second
to third year of life,
they go from being anorexic,
of having no appetite,
to becoming hypophagic and
they become massively obese,
but I'm just going to be focusing on
the symptoms that these children have
in the immediate perinatal period.
So this girl is showing the hypertonia
of Prader-Willi syndrome.
Most individuals with
Prader-Willi syndrome
have a deletion of the paternal copy
of this chromosome, so they've only got
maternally expressed genes coming
from this region and no paternal copy.
A few other people have
two maternal copies
of this region, and they
have Prader-Willi syndrome,
so what this is showing is
that Prader-Willi syndrome
is caused by the absence
of expression of genes
that come from the father.
Interestingly in individuals with maternal
uniparental disomy,
this is one of the most
penetrate causes of psychosis.
Sitting down in this region of the region,
this is a GABA receptor cluster,
and there appears to
be some sort of parent
of origin affected carrying here
that is predisposing these individuals
to developing psychosis.
So Prader-Willi syndrome is associated
with the absence of expression
of paternally-derived genes,
and therefore evolutionary, this leads
to a prediction that Prader-Willi syndrome
should exhibit an exaggeration of traits
that reduce demands on mother.
So this region contains
paternal accelerators
on offspring demands on mothers.
We're taking away those paternal genes,
and so you should see in the child
reduced demands on the mother.
So let's look at the neonatal phenotype
in Prader-Willi syndrome.
It's associated with low muscle tension,
neonatal hypotonia, with a weak cry,
these are low maintenance children,
and with poor suck.
So these children have
little to no interest
in feeding, and they have
very weak or non-existing
suckling reflexes.
Usually they have to have a tube
put into the stomach, gavage feeding,
to give them adequate nutrition.
They show excessive sleepiness.
The child is put to bed
and it stays asleep.
So this suggests that paternal genes
that are absent in Prader-Willi syndrome
promote suckling and they also promote
wakefulness, so in their absence,
you have a child that doesn't suckle
and a child that sleeps through the night.
And I have suggested that evolutionarily,
paternal genes are promoting more intense
suckling and also night
waking in children,
in babies, as a way of essentially
exhausting mothers and delaying her return
to fertility, delaying the conception
of a younger sibling who will compete
for maternal care and attention.
Interestingly, deletion of precisely
the same chromosome region
cause a completely different syndrome.
This is a boy with Angelman syndrome.
The majority of cases, 70% of
cases of Angelman syndrome,
have a deletion of the
same chromosome region,
but in this case, it's a deletion
of the maternal chromosome, so they only
have a paternal copy of this region.
So now we would expect an
exaggeration of behaviors
that increase costs to mothers.
We know of a couple of cases of women
with Prader-Willi syndrome
who had a deletion
of their paternal
chromosome that were fertile
and had a child and passed
the deletion on to their children.
Their child got it from their mother,
so the child of a Prader-Willi
syndrome woman has Angelman syndrome.
Some other individuals
with Prader-Willi syndrome
have an activating
mutations in this gene here,
UBE3A, which is normally
expressed only on the maternal chromosome,
so now the maternal copy
is inactivated by mutation,
and the paternal copy is
inactivated by genomic imprinting,
and this suggests that Angelman syndrome,
most of the symptoms,
are caused by the absence
of expression of the maternally derived
copy of this gene, UBED3A.
So Angelman syndrome is predicted
to exaggerate traits that increase
offspring demands on mothers,
and I'll just look at some of the
symptoms of Angelman syndrome.
So Angelman syndrome is associated
with uncoordinated suck and swallow,
but these children do not
need to be gavage fed.
It's as if there's hyper
activity in the suckling reflex.
They get adequate nutrition, so they don't
show failure to thrive.
They have adequate
nutrition as I've mentioned.
They are hypertonic rather than hypotonic.
They have ataxia, hyperactivity,
particularly tiring for parents,
they have excessive wakefulness as babies.
I know of clinical reports of babies
who were awake 21 hours out of 24.
Parents are advised to get some sleep.
Sometimes to put the child
in a darkened room and close the door.
Angelman syndrome is
associated with happy affect,
the laughing, smiling child you saw
in the previous picture,
this is particular
in interactions with potential caregivers,
and it's associated
with frequent laughter.
These are happy, smiling children.
Curiously, this is
associated with the complete
absence of the development of speech
or even of sign language,
so these children
have some degree of cognitive delay,
but the absence of speech seems to be
out of proportion to
the cognitive problems.
It seems to be a specific deficit
in this imprinted disorder.
The suggestion is that children
with Angelman syndrome exhibit
exaggerated attachment behaviors
that normally engage maternal attention
and elicit maternal care.
This is the laughing, smiling baby
the mother wants to put
attention, give attention to,
and I'll finish with another photo,
and just look at the hands in the photo.
So here we have Mom
holding on to the hands
of two children, and this child misses out
and doesn't get a maternal hand.
Thank you.
(piano music)